premio tieni premuto si va beh lo sa c'è
un mostro oddio c'è un mostro nel cesso
aieta nonni motorino dove torna da me
motorino perché ti sei preso due prendi
anche me prende anche metti su oddio
oddio no no no scherzavo scherza cic ha
risucchiato col sesso non credo che
l'ascensore
ok invece funziona a modo suo mi sembra
una no ho vomitato un braccio cazzo
lavora che controlliamo st porta se non
c'è nulla di strano [ __ ] cosa dice che
non dovevamo dio
[Musica]
clicca sul bersaglio per sparare a
lanciare brutto stronzo
no non culliamoci dei pappagalli di
pezza che si spostano da soli perché è
sporca [ __ ] cioè che cazzo di livello
dovrebbe essere questo
[Musica]
denis dal primo perché poi se dovete la
infilo dammi la birra donna dammi la
barra damista potuta birra a costo di
staccarti l'amore ti sta bene frutta
[ __ ] ci prova dai cani quelli a bordo o
banca ma basta
[Musica]
86 bellocchio e veloce veloce
velocissimo
sì sì c'è la bandiera c'è la bandiera
maniera gela bandiera o vi giuro che a
sto punto è meglio start un argento che
fuori non da un attimo che
cosa fa la radio al marrone trovato
altro pistola luke era sul comodino la
prossima volta lascino ordini giocattoli
questa è la cucina core [ __ ] chi
cazzo sei fammi uscire allora è questa e
la cucina trovati la tua nutella come si
apre porto dove andare dove andare a
deleghe ai play the game
ragazze
il welcome to the fastest jump eva sei
sempre sotto medici ci metto anche la
musica
cosa devo fare qui
che cazzo dici è stato dato
[Musica]
un ai quattro formaggi e una prosciutto
grazie a questa pazzia polizia
questa è sporta ma perché cazzo fanno
ecco qui questi cosa sola banca non
basta
la faccenda sta diventando brutta
compresa
[ __ ] che cazzo bbc sul paranormale
pattumiera quello tacco su facebook e il
loro vino schiacci vuole la musica
indiana jones raga forse lo ha fatto a
partire nel momento sbagliato voglio
adesso è che cazzo sentite è forse la
musica di indiana jones non mi conviene
tanto visto che sto morendo per adesso
ce lo fa perché non messo la musica bene
mai mai mai così grande direi che
possiamo rifarlo a partire
già fatto a cliccare non ce la faccio
ragazzi
[Musica]
ok ok ok ragazzi ce la posso fare
non va bene l'ho ripassato di quel salto
di questa alto sì sì sì no no no si si
eh no kat
cos'è sta roba cedono picchiare gesù
madonna il verde è morto che fu eletto
la mia sai dove telo fico questo il
gioco consiste nel non muoversi vi
ricordo a tutti quanti quindi state
fermi pupa si può togliere la l'allarme
che prima non c'era un uscita [ __ ]
culo voglio la mia [ __ ] birra adesso
non me ne vado di qui finché non ho la
mia birra punizione
[Musica]
cos'è
chi è povero porca [ __ ] il tu non sai
che sei qui in azioni di velocemente
potevo fare
mi ha avviato da con un gatto milano fu
un piatto vecchia soluzione di merda
basta come gatto vecchia o di non
tornare indietro c'è creduto che mario
mi affoga escono in fantasmi suv c'è
spongebob che cazzo ti posso dire che ci
possa arrivare ci posso arrivare sì sì
sì sì sì sì no no
[Musica]
gara sono una birra poi guardate
guardate la tv tranquilli cambiate
canale che queste tv spazzatura ragazzi
sono sicuro che mi devo pensare di merda
sempre da the mad o all'altro sesso
opposto
bacchette magiche incantesimi mai così
cioè dove dove se l'è infilata st
bacchetta ragazzi ci siete che poi lo
mando via italia 1 non vedo un cazzo
aspetti nonno ciak perché c'è ragazzotto
mi avete detto ho vinto e ho vinto io ti
sei fermato prima via ho vinto io
[Musica]
amico mio
siamo induista [ __ ] stanza perché
cazzo sussurri che cos'è sta roba mi fa
così schifo
secondo le parole parole vale lei voleva
capitana bianco non ti avvicinare al
palo non ti avvicinare al bar o da ho
detto di non toccare il palo dove cazzo
siamo finiti quattro ma [ __ ] pure
tu perché non c'è il naso sei parente di
voldemort
bisogna viaggiare i voti prego dimmi che
ci arrivo
[Musica]
grazie dio grazie si è chiuso il gioco
questo mi sta ingrossando maledizione
togli il tuo pene dal mio bene senti e
la pizza la pizza credo che lei abbia le
elezioni come mi accorgo che non solo
non ne sono sicuro non ne sono sicuro da
lettere comando grazie
dammi il braccio i rom ma vabbè senza
feriti iscrivetevi e noi ci andiamo in
un prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]
non c'è niente
devo sollevare il cervello del paziente
ma dopo ok giochi okaka è qualcosa di
epico
guardate che oddio cosa ho
[Musica]
ci sono sempre e comunque sta diventando
che tantissima cosa c'è una ics in fondo
cazzo come ci arrivo
tana [ __ ] ma che cazzo erano [ __ ]